there are lingering concerns and
questions and criticism of quarterback
carson wentz who played extremely well
last year especially down the stretch
when he was surrounded by a cast of no
names and he willed the team to the post
season from five and seven to nine and
seven
now this year wentz has struggled
and
that has prompted brett favre
close friend of eagles coach doug
peterson former teammates in green bay
favre was on first take on espn and he
said i think once is very capable i
think we're all in agreement that he has
the tools actually thought they should
have kept
nick foles rather than carson wentz just
based off of production and where they
got to you know they won a super bowl
with falls farf said they're obviously
banking on wence's upside but how many
more years do you let him linger before
you stick with him or cut
bait
man i thought they should have kept nick
foles rather than carson weinstein i
recall two years ago
when nick foles was leading
the eagles on the postseason path the
double doink game upset a bears team
that won the nfc north then gave the
saints everything they could handle yeah
sean jeffrey drops a pass maybe the
eagles win that game with nick foles and
get back to the final four and as they
got farther and farther i'm saying you
need to have the conversation you can't
just say carson wentz is our guy because
we traded up the number two to get him
he's our guy he's our guy he's our guy
you can't do that when nick foles has
won the super bowl mvp and almost taking
you back to the nfc championship game it
can't be automatic you have to at least
think it through i never got the
impression they thought it through chris
maybe they should have thought it
through well i i i think they did think
it through you know i i do
you know first off i always go back to
what something i always say i mean the
2017 eagles with carson wenzel
quarterback was the best eagles team i
ever saw i mean it's the best i ever saw
they were dominant he was unstoppable
that was amazing no has it been a great
year for carson wentz i understand that
i get it you know let's not forget
though back in that time in 2017
the eagles went into the playoffs
so concerned with nick foles
they like i i can't i mean they were
like a legit concern you know they
barely beat the falcons in the
divisional game 15 to 10. you know in
week 16 they played the giants he was
like 19 or not giants uh
uh the raiders he was like 19 to 38 you
know nothing special you know the
playoff game was nothing special we're
forgetting that
like whoa eagles you're overlooking
you're overlooking two fairly
significant games well the nfc
championship game in the super bowl i'm
gonna i'm gonna get there but kind of
kind of big games i know but okay so but
but we're getting i'm just framing the
picture i get it that was great that was
awesome yes i get it those two games
were great they really were he played
really well um yes but like why why
couldn't have carson once done that i i
don't understand now the next year he
gets to start the season and show us
nick foles
take over go ahead oh that's right he
played average and didn't so they went
back to carson wentz who was coming off
an acl injury now carson wentz in that
year he gets to play he's still getting
his feet underneath him the team is hurt
he doesn't have al shawn jeffrey and
some of these receivers there then when
he gets hurt nick foles comes in and all
those receivers come back and they get
healthy so they get a little bit better
and they go on the double doing playoff
run like you're talking about but with
all that said okay and carson wentz is
having a down year and i understand that
but what what is nick falls doing the
last two years that makes everybody
think like oh
it's a slam dunk carson wentz was
amazing at the end of last year nick
foles got put on the bench for gardner
minshew who was going to the bench as a
full-time backup quarterback after this
year's over
and now he's in chicago and tell me how
that offense looks right now tell me
well but is it but now they have better
weapons in philadelphia they have better
weapons right now better weapons
they don't have it they don't have the
offensive line you can't complain about
matt nagy over and over and over again
and now blame it on nick falls that he's
not playing i i talk about doug peterson
just as much and the philly offense
aligned with all those injuries that
ain't anything special i mean that's
nothing special they're not doing
anything carson once does not have alan
robinson anthony miller jimmy graham
cole comet um who else i'll miss oh
daryl mooney who runs 4-3 he doesn't
none of that he would be way better if
he did he would be way better so
i get like brett i just i think it's a
lazy take by brett favre i'm sorry i
don't know what to say it's lazy
here here's here's the reality here's
the reality
um
it's three years ago why are we talking
about it the fact well i got a theory
for that coming up hang on bear with me
the fact that the eagles
traded up to number two to get once
picnic foals the super bowl mvp three
years ago over or picked wence over
falls and then gave wence the 33 million
dollar contract i feel like
that that is all weighing on went yeah i
feel like
he believes he needs
in one moment in one play i i i feel
like he thinks on every given play
it's incumbent on him to prove
in that moment
that they did the right thing when they
traded up to draft him when they picked
him over falls and when they paid him
and it's impossible for him to justify
it in one play but i feel like that's
what he's trying to do this year chris
mike i agree every it's like our old
desean watson you know the first year or
two in the nfl right it's like every
play feels like it's the last play of
the game the last play of the super bowl
and it's just sometimes just like throw
the ball away take the sack stop doing
stupid things listen it's not been a
good year there's no doubt about that i
mean you know he was the number six
quarterback in my quarterback rankings
this year he i'm going to do a top ten
quarterbacks in football next week he's
not in the top ten there's no way you
could do that there is still big time
talent there but yeah he has an issue
with trying to do too much and it puts
them in some tough spots but i also
argue in that
that they can't do a lot unless he does
a lot either so he he is in an
unenviable position where he's the guy
that has to make things happen and he
just hasn't figured out that way of
balancing it of you know like we see the
really good ones that are in those
positions like a russell wilson and
everybody else where they can balance it
usually from toeing the line of being
crazy and oh i'm pushing the limits of
being aggressive bam i got it coachable
boom
[Laughter]
okay one last point on the foals versus
wentz question yeah
because i i think that this gives it
real merit
dollar for dollar right dollar for
dollar
i think it's a lot closer
right yeah i think it makes it a close
question because you could have kept
goals for a lot less than wentz and that
means you got more money to go out there
and get other guys to make your team
better yeah i i think you're that's
probably right too you're right you know
i listen i think your point about the
contract the fact that foals had already
won the super bowl and all that has all
led to carson wentz like every week like
this is the week i'm gonna prove
everybody wrong it's me i'm the guy i'm
this quarterback and you just can't do
that you know i i don't know he just
right now
he has to understand the big picture of
the football game and i'll say this too
here's another thing i don't love about
carson wentz and you know i'm a big
defender but this is to me where like i
wish he would change a little bit i
always hear these stories about he
listens to nothing right he knows
nothing about what's being said or going
on about him on our sunday night
football game against the 49ers a few
weeks ago i wanted to bring this up
because
chris collinsworth and al michaels
talked about that and one of the things
they brought up was that wence had no
idea that the philadelphia 76ers his
home city had just hired doc rivers
that's how
oblivious he is to what's going on in
the world and what's being said i don't
know if that's necessarily a good thing
i don't you know at some point you got
to like listen and just be a part of the
culture of the city in a little bit and
hey yeah it's philadelphia when you play
good they'll lift you up in a chair and
hurrah hurrah when you stink yeah
they're going to tell you you suck and
probably a bunch of other four-letter
words that's the way how they do
business there get get over it it's nfl
quarterback so i don't know that kind of
bothered me does that i don't know why
it did but it's just like it's like it's
it's too oblivious to the world and
what's going on
who's doc rivers
the cut the basketball coach you know
the old oh
he told me to say you scared me for a
second cause i was like
am i thinking of somebody else and said
the wrong game
let's let's hear let's hear
from doug peterson with his thoughts on
what his good friend brett favre had to
say about nick foles versus carson wentz
i respect uh brett's opinion you know i
mean
yeah we are friends but um i haven't i
haven't talked to him and he's entitled
to that and uh
um
that's about it when the decision had to
be made in the organization
it even though personnel decisions like
that are usually tough it probably
wasn't that difficult for you guys was
words anyone beating down the door to do
a different thing
with in regards to nick terms of keeping
nick over carson
no carson's our guy carson's our draft
pick carson's the guy that uh is is
going to carry us and and and lead this
football team and and listen everybody's
entitled to their own opinion those
aren't those aren't my words those
aren't howie's words jeffrey's words
those are his words i mean that i
respect that opinion whatever he wants
to say that that's fine and
we're going to remain friends it doesn't
doesn't bother me one way or the other
all i know is that carson wentz is our
guy
yeah look i don't expect doug peterson
to throw a friendship with brett favre
just because fard said something because
here's the thing peterson probably knows
well i'm not going to say probably
peterson knows farv well enough to know
he's kind of dumb and he's probably not
going to be bothered by something that
his good friend who's kind of dumb has
to say why get mad about it he's my good
friend and he's kind of dumb one day two
things not mutually exclusively i don't
have any feelings there floria or
anything holy cow wait wait wait are you
disputing my conclusion after nearly 30
years of following the career of brett
favre that he's kind of dumb well i i
don't know if i'm willing to say that i
is a little bit of a knucklehead at
times sure what's the difference
knucklehead what's the difference
somebody that can just get a little like
caught up in certain situations go crazy
okay all right well you know if that's
the case then i'm dumb too brett so i'm
in the club with you okay because i
definitely am classified as a
knucklehead but i think to your pr your
point there like you the the premise of
what you're saying is right first off
yeah of course it's two football guys
and you're never gonna see things eye to
eye on all subjects you know i don't
care who it is it's you're gonna have
differences and things like that but i
think like what you're saying to the
point of i think doug peterson's going i
don't think brett favre is watching film
of carson wentz and really studying him
and watching nick foles and what he's
doing right now to where he goes i just
know more i'm studying it and yeah and
he can just kind of brush it off his
shoulders that way
brett favre's kind of got that terry
bradshaw presence in the media where you
don't have to really know what's going
on you just have to be yourself
and people will listen and assume that
you know what you're talking about even
if from time to time you don't and i
don't mean that as an insult to farver
bradshaw that's capitalizing on their
natural charisma the fact that people
still admire them and respect them and
they achieved on the field the kind of
things that allow them to just kind of
barnstorm in with whatever hot take pops
into their brain right even if it's
ultimately uninformed now
that's that's the best compliment i can
give them now
let me go next level here let me suggest
and i don't know that i believe this but
it's just kind of fun to think about
whether or not this is going on here
what if well what if
what if brett favre deliberately
did what he did and said what he said
with doug peterson
knowing it's coming and maybe at some
level wanting it to happen as a way to
get wentz to snap out of it your
thoughts
i don't think so i that that would be
next level st i don't think so i don't
know if i could buy that listen brett
favre is not capable of that i don't
know yeah i just don't see the stars
aligning for that one listen some of
your conspiracies okay i can get behind
i can't i'm not saying look i'm not
saying i believe it you're right you're
just throwing a thought out there i get
it and sometimes hey crap like that we
know can happen in the nfl but i don't
know if this is one of those i think
you're i think you're right okay brett
favre is just a person wait wait wait
wait it's an extension of rex ryan
telling one of his players to go start a
a fight
to see how tough that guy is it's the
same idea yeah you're right it goes on
something phony yeah to see how someone
reacts to it right right you know but i
i don't know you know that's where i got
into the wins thing too who he doesn't
he doesn't pay attention to anything and
he was so oblivious to that like i don't
know does he know does he know this is a
conversation today you know about brett
favre and doug peterson i don't know the
way he answers things and sometimes i
just go no i think he really
like most quarterbacks say i don't pay
attention but they pay attention but
they don't read all the article right
they just go oh that's what they're
saying about me and they move on like he
seems like he is really like
no clue what's going on and being said
about him and i don't like i said i
don't know if that's always a good
thing i still feel like at some level he
continues to fight those demons that
come from ending up at north dakota
state and constantly trying to prove
yourself yeah and when you throw on top
of it the faith that the organization
continues to show in you when the fan
base doesn't want that faith to be shown
when at least elements of the fan base
don't want it there's going to be
reaction when they trade up to get
carson wentz reaction when they pick
whence over falls reaction when they
give wentz 33 million a year
it's it's it's not easy it's not easy
and uh i think he's capable of being a
great quarterback and when i look at his
contract
i think that the two are bound together
through 2021. okay after 2021 right all
bets are off and and frankly if they
don't turn it around by the end of 2021
it may be a new coach it may be a new gm
yeah it might be deciding on who the
next quarterback's gonna be yeah it
might be even with that super bowl
trophy this is just part of the reality
of being in philly well you don't get a
grace period for five years just because
you won a championship no you're right
about that i'm telling you this though
i'm not giving up on philly yet i'm not
you know the defense is pretty damn good
this year
and you know i just again if they could
just get a little healthier here
it really just one more guy a wide
receiver they could just come back i'd
go watch out you know there is some
things there about their football team
so you know desean jackson the high
ankle sprain alshon jeffrey i mean i
don't is he ever going to be back i mean
i hear i don't know
i just like to me that is when
carson wentz might finally be able to
take a deep breath and go whoa well cow
i got somebody that's open i got
somebody that could throw to when they
are covered and trust them and he
doesn't have that luxury right now it's
basically folgum or nothing
let me just say this
seahawks packers
saints oh cardinals oh that quartet of
opponents is coming up in consecutive
weeks 12 through 15.
now they still may win enough games
to get to the postseason but that's
going to be the opportunity for the
eagles to show
that they can go toe-to-toe with the
great team and hey look they gave the
steelers everything they could handle
ravens too several weeks ago in the
chase in the chase clay pool game yeah
and they gave they gave the the ravens
everything they could handle so we'll
see how it plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports